you
after nearly a decade the beloved HBO
series Game of Thrones came to an end
last night leading up to the finale more
than a million disappointed viewers
petitioned for the final season to be
remade altogether CBS News correspondent
and CBS n anchor vladimir duthiers is
here with the stress of pulling off the
perfect ending flag good morning good
morning
first of all a promise if you haven't
seen last night's finale
there will be no spoilers here but
particularly the reviews are mixed one
critic called the episode a disaster
another called it a satisfying and proof
that even the most acclaimed series
struggle to get finales right finalizing
the rightful claim to the Iron Throne
marks a pop-culture milestone joining
iconic series finales from Newhart to
Breaking Bad
[Music]
I'm sure glad we went through it
together an historic 105 million people
tune in when the sitcom mash called it
quits penny oh do we have to go Big Bang
Theory executive producer steve holland
co-wrote last week's series finale we
knew there was a lot of pressure from
fans but honestly a lot of that pressure
came from ourselves too and really
wanting to get this right because
getting it wrong contained a show's
legacy I think it's gonna be okay
when sign fell ended after nine seasons
fans were largely disappointed when the
central characters wound up in jail
that's not so bad
and that was before the age of social
media if you read the internet you will
read the worst thing that you've ever
ever thought in your darkest deepest
moment that anyone would ever say about
you The Sopranos finale cut to black
seemingly mid-sea
but like many finales it generated
plenty of conversation that creates an
excitement for people to gather around
the next day and talked about it and
praise it and criticize it and and that
becomes this sort of communal part of
the show I think that is as much a part
of the show is what ends up you know on
television as reactions to the last
night's ending a mass on the Internet
Game of Thrones writers are trying to
stay away from the social media fray
there are mental health exactly in one
interview writer David bind-off said of
the finale
I plan to be very drunk and very far
from the internet oh yeah why stress you
said you liked it you actually liked it
I just think the Mearing mixed reviews
online so a season which a lot of people
a lot of fans felt rushed over the last
couple of seasons this was probably the
most satisfying ending you could hope
for it could have been better as a huge
fan of The Game of Thrones I've read all
the books it could have been better but
what are the best finales I saw was six
feet under back in the day I thought
that was mash in Mad Men are my two
favorites well they made about The
Sopranos which I didn't particularly
care for him when David Chase was here
and I asked him you know I don't know
about that fella he goes well how would
you have ended would you come up with
think about these endings changes over
times we that's a lot of people did like
the Seinfeld ending now thank you very
much bad always good to see you